okay let's now get into this crazy
situation that we have to discuss the
the guy who died supposedly from taking
Trump's proposed cure for coronavirus
Donald Trump has been touting
chloroquine and hydroxychloroquine as a
possible cure or prevention for
coronavirus now it is true that
chloroquine with and without
azithromycin is being studied in a mega
trial that the w-h-o is running as one
of four possible treatments for some
people in some cases we just don't know
yet but this has been amplified by all
sorts of people around Donald Trump and
Donald Trump himself and a man has now
died after obtaining and taking what he
believed was the medication chloroquine
but was actually a fish tank cleaning
product that shares an ingredient with
chloroquine so once again almost all the
headlines are wrong about this a whole
bunch of people are saying the guy died
from getting the treatment Trump
suggested that's not true the guy didn't
take medical chloroquine which of course
you can't just buy it's got to be
prescribed by doctors it would be done
so only in very specific settings where
the patient would be a good candidate
for that according to this guy's widow
he kept seeing Trump and people around
from say this could cure coronavirus
this could prevent coronavirus so the 68
year old went out and got chloroquine
phosphate he thought it was the
medication chloroquine of course it
wasn't because that medication you can't
just go out and buy the guy went out and
got the fish tank cleaner it's not a
medication and the fact that he was able
to just go buy it should have been a
signal that it's not the medication the
man died and the woman is now in
critical condition now a bunch of people
wrote to me and they said you know we
really shouldn't worry much about this
this is a sort of Darwin Award situation
you've got to be really dumb to do
something like this still we've been
saying Trump talking about chloroquine
like it's a game changer can only cause
problems it's not going to create any
solutions and right away we have one
such example how in
is it that people are literally drinking
chemicals on Trump's say-so out of
confusion it's not the chemical Trump
suggested right it's reminding me though
of Jonestown where the phrase to drink
the kool-aid originated Jim Jones and
the Jonestown cult it's tragic
it doesn't get more cultish than this
Trump says chloroquine and people go out
and buy something that sounds like it
drink it and one person has already died
whatever you think about this guy's
intelligence it's a truly depressing
story it's heartbreaking and
unfortunately we're going in the
direction of more death not less death
and that's very scary particularly as
Donald Trump again is increasingly
hinting that he wants to let it rip to
take a page out of dr. Anthony foul his
vocabulary say just get back to work
we've made a calculation that the number
of deaths that that will cause is a fair
trade for whatever economic recovery
Trump thinks will happen if he tells
people to get back to work have you ever
wanted to learn to play the guitar but
you've had trouble committing to the
time and money required to actually take
lessons I have the perfect solution for
you it's called fender play it's an app
developed by the iconic guitar company
fender it lets you learn to play your
favorite songs in minutes on your
schedule with interactive video lessons
that are very easy to follow you can use
it for guitar bass or ukulele I've been
using fender play to learn the ukulele
I've gotten a lot better than I thought
I would in a couple of months I had
tried teaching myself using some YouTube
videos didn't really get anywhere night
and day difference since I've started
using fender play and they have
personalized learning paths that will
cater to your musical tastes you can use
it on your phone tablet or computer and
you learn at your own pace which is just
awesome
one year of membership gives you access
to thousands of lessons for less than
the cost of one traditional in-person
lesson and when you go to fender dot-com
slash Pakman you'll get to try it
totally free for two whole weeks free
two week trial don't lose out on that
without any commitment that's F en
our comm slash Pakman PA KMA and fender
dot-com slash Pakman